Hans gorg msen Germany's former head of
the office to counter right-wing
extremism is now reportedly under
investigation for right-wing extremism
kind of funny huh according to the Press
Masen has landed on the wrong side of
the office he used to lead because of
his quote increasingly radical
commentary on mass migration into
Germany The Man spent a lot of time
researching what is going on in Germany
and after learning a lot he ended up on
the right now I am not particularly
interested in German politics but I am
interested in the political principle
that can be deduced from this case
namely that the greatest predictor of
right-wing extremism
today is knowledge of politics